there's the Dallas Skyline because
something remarkable or what counts as
remarkable these days happened in Texas
over the weekend attorney general Ken
Paxton a republican became just a third
person ever to be impeached in that
state and he was impeached by
Republicans wasn't even a close vote in
the GOP controlled State House you know
Paxton as a close Ally of former
president Donald Trump he got reelected
despite facing criminal charges related
to a previous matter he's denied all
wrongdoing and Omar villafranca is here
to explain what finally got his own
party to turn against him
a majority of Texas House Republicans
voted to impeach one of their own
Saturday the resolution is adopted
acting to oust the state's attorney
general Ken Paxton he put the interest
of himself above the laws of the State
of Texas lawmakers began investigating
Paxton back in March after he asked for
3.3 million dollars in taxpayer money to
settle a whistleblower lawsuit filed by
staffers whom Paxton fired after they
went to the FBI with their corruption
allegations the 20 articles of
impeachment include charges of not only
misappropriation of public resources but
also bribery obstruction of justice and
conspiracy Houston representative Ann
Johnson is on the house investigative
committee the exposure of the felony
crimes that Ken Paxton has done is the
kind that would erode the public Trust
in the statement Paxton denied the
allegations and denounced the
proceedings as illegal unethical and
profoundly unjust ring the bell some
lawmakers who voted against impeachment
questioned the process it's what I call
the hang of now and judge them later
policy Paxton's attorney says any
alleged wrongdoings should be left to
the courts there are new criminal
charges here that have been filed so the
process I think is deeply flawed in
terms of denying a due process whether
Paxton's removal will become permanent
will ultimately lie with the Texas
Senate where his wife is a senator she
has not yet said whether she'll recuse
herself from her husband's trial
proceedings for CBS mornings Omar via
Franca Dallas